what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU and of course the
Spider-Man Sony Universe the spumc the
spider-verse whatever they are calling
it nowadays there have been some pretty
big reveals recently thanks to some set
photos from Madam Webb as it turns out
it does look like Sony indeed has a plan
for their spider-verse it looks like
Madam Webb is going to be a lot more
important than we thought it would be
and it does look like Sony is indeed
going to build their Universe to have a
major event much like Avengers end game
but actually it's kind of going to be
more like Avengers Secret Wars it's
actually going to be a combination of
both Avengers and game and Secret Wars
we're going to have the Multiverse
involved we'll have a lot of variants
but it's only going to be one Universe
it's all going to take place inside of
one Universe however multiple variants
will be in that one universe so lots to
talk about today including a possible
big bad for Sony's Spider-Man universe
it looks like they might have actually
done that and it is rather cool so let's
dive into it and of course if you're new
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest Spider-Man and
of course MCU news so as I mentioned
this comes from some set photos of
Madame Webb now if you're not familiar
with what Madame web is Madame Webb is a
character in the comics who can travel
the Multiverse and in the comics she is
essentially a cosmic entity now Madam
Webb is good I've heard some people talk
about how she could be bad I don't think
that's going to be the case in the Sony
spider-verse I believe she'll be good
and I believe that she'll be a very very
important character moving forward in
fact Madame Webb is probably going to be
the biggest and most important movie
that is taking place inside of the
spider-verse that we've ever had so far
and that is because she truly is going
to set up the Multiverse in the
spider-verse yes we've had Spider-Man no
way home but realize that that takes
place in the MCU and yes there is kind
of a blurred line between the MCU and
the spider-verse and now that the
Multiverse is is existing in both
universes I suppose we can get a
crossover between the universes because
we basically already did with Andrew
Garfield and Tobey Maguire Spider-Man
however as most people know you're not
going to see anybody like Sam Wilson's
Captain America show up in the
spider-verse but this is leading to
something much bigger a huge
spider-verse that is pretty much just a
bunch of different Spider-Man variants
and of course other awesome Spider-Man
characters as well will have Peter
Parker of course but then we'll have
spider Gwen Miles Morales we'll have the
Scarlet Spider spider Punk a bunch of
different versions of Spider-Man and
people with Spider-Man powers and
they're all about to come together in
one Universe because it looks like the
main big bad of Sony's universe is about
to come into play in Madame web and it
looks like he's going to be hunting down
a bunch of different Spider-Man in a
bunch of different universes and if
things are going to go the way I think
they are going to go and what insiders
are saying this is actually about to get
really really good of course that
depends if they pull it off of course
course and they do it the right way but
the idea and the concept is there and
it's phenomenal so check this out I'll
explain and tie it all together we've
got some recent photos from the set of
Madame Webb and it shows us this person
in what appears to be some type of
Spider-Man outfit now before we get into
if he's a Spider-Man variant or not
because he definitely looks like it
let's talk about the actor because this
actor definitely looks like it's Aaron
Taylor Johnson who is supposed to be
playing Craven the hunter at first I
thought well okay Multiverse that's real
however despite really looking like him
in these photos apparently this is the
actor Tahir Rahim so it is not Aaron
Taylor Johnson it is not some type of
variant of Craven the hunter but of
course now the question is is he some
type of variant of Spider-Man well
apparently not according to The Insider
accounts can we get some toast they said
I've heard he's allegedly Ezekiel Sims
the Terminator of this movie if you will
however they went on to say not 100 on
this though now for those of you who
know the name Ezekiel Sims you know that
things are about to get very very
exciting however it does look like
they're going to twist it up a little
bit Ezekiel Sims is not bad in the
comics however this Insider says that
he's going to be the villain of this
film and he could possibly even be a big
bad of this entire Spider-Man universe
or be working for a big bad of the
universe but like I mentioned Ezekiel
Sims is good in the comics and he's
granted the powers of a spider totem now
for those who may not know what a spider
totem is it's essentially a multiversal
entity a sort of cosmic entity that was
created by the Elder goddess niith and
they are linked to a Mystical Force
called the web of life and Destiny and
this is essentially what Madame Webb can
look at to look into other universes
look into the entire Multiverse and
travel throughout it as well the web of
life and Destiny is essentially the
entire Multiverse a model of it that
allows people to travel through it so
although Ezekiel Sims may be bad in this
movie we can can kind of see how
everything is starting to connect this
is going to be a major movie for the
Spider-Man universe introducing the web
of life and Destiny the true big
Multiverse as a whole inside of the
spider-verse and they could even
possibly introduce spider totems which
would be really really cool these spider
deities essentially can actually choose
avatars and Peter Parker has been an
avatar before for the one called the
other and of course other spider
variants can be chosen by other spider
totems this whole concept to bring into
the spider-verse is a really great idea
and if Sony is about to go into the
direction that I think they're going to
go into the Sony Spider-Man universe is
about to be amazing and Spider-Man no
way home could have just been the start
of seeing Spider-Man variants now
according to can we get some toast
Ezekiel simps will be the villain and is
going to be a sort of Terminator meaning
this person is going to be hunting down
different Spider-Man variants in
different universes and I really really
like this idea and it sounds like a big
setup like I mentioned for a big bad
someone who was hell-bent on getting rid
of all of the different types of
Spider-Man variants perhaps to try and
get to the Web of Life and Destiny
somehow or to gain all of the powers of
all of the spider totems for that one
person that is definitely a power that
one person would like to have and if
there are no Spider-Man variants left
anymore the spider totems can't exactly
choose avatars so it is sort of a weird
twist that they would have Ezekiel Sims
be a bad guy but it's not the first time
we've seen that done and the reason that
I think that this could be a big bad is
because rumor has it some insiders have
reported that Sony is building up to a
spider get in and again this is
essentially Avengers endgame slash
Avengers Secret Wars where all of the
different variants of Spider-Man come
together in one universe and the main
Universe actually there have been
stories where Spider-Man have gone to
other universes outside of the main
universe but this is one where everybody
comes to the main one and essentially in
the comics there's almost every single
Spider-Man variant there so just think
of Avengers endgame where you saw all of
these other different Heroes on screen
that's what we're going to get if we get
the spider get a movie Spider-Man spider
Gwen Miles Morales Spider-Man 2099 heck
they could even bring all of the
different Spider-Man variants from into
the spider-verse into the real live
action spider-verse it could be
absolutely insane and of course it's
Spider-Man so this could be one of the
biggest movies of all time if this is
indeed going to happen and is indeed the
true direction that Sony is heading
which I believe they should do after all
we know they've been working with Kevin
feige a lot about every Spider-Man
project they have going on so it would
make sense that he would advise them and
they would listen to his advice to kind
of have a big bad of the entire universe
to connect it with a villain and then
bring everybody together this could be
way bigger than Spider-Man no way home
this could actually blow Spider-Man no
way home out of the water and I love
that movie so that's saying something so
this could be a complete and total game
changer for the Spider-Man universe
verse it could completely turn it around
and make it something fantastic and I
really hope that's the direction that
they're going but hey let me know what
you think about all of this in the
comments down below would you like to
see this happen or not don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
so you can stay updated on all things
Spider-Man and the MCU don't forget to
like the video and for live updates you
can follow me on Instagram and Twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof